[Musique]
bienvenue dans le grand studio du figaro
on est en direct on est avec vous c'est
figaro live et on attend vos points de
vue autour de la nouvelle tribune des
militaires c'est la tendance première
sur twitter et des réseaux sociaux
ces dernières heures des militaires en
fonction et donc tribune cette fois-ci
anonyme
alors alors trouvez vous comme gérald
darmanin que cet anonymat traduit un
manque de courage vous allez nous donner
vos points de vue on va en débattre
on va en débattre avec addictions de
vecchio journaliste au service des bas
et opinions du figaro en charge de
figaro vox et auteur de recomposition le
nouveau monde populiste on en débat
également avec christophe de bugs
spécialiste de rhétorique politique
historien et professeur à sciences po et
membre de la prestigieuse fondation pour
l'innovation politique
la fondapol on reviendra aussi sur le
week-end de violences urbaines dans le
sud dans l'est en région parisienne
alors quelle réponse à cette vague
d'insécurité
à l'heure où on rend hommage avec club
beaucoup d'émotion à au brigadier éric
masson et ou alors on doit avoir de
nouvelles précisions sur l' enquête en
cours des interpellations réalisées ces
dernières heures pour l'heure pour
l'heure on va revenir sur la polémique
du jour
l'adn des dernières heures si nous ne
pouvons pas réglementairement nous
exprimer à visage découvert il nous est
tout aussi impossible de nous taire
c'est ce qu'on peut lire dans la
nouvelle tribune publiée par nos
confrères de valeurs actuelles
alors selon nos confrères elle émanerait
de militaires d'activé c'est-à-dire
militaire actuellement en activité
ce dont doute d'après bfm tv d'état
major quoi qu'il en soit quels que
soient les auteurs le nombre d'auteurs
le texte énerve et en particulier le
texte énerve au gouvernement en
particulier là encore le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin
quelle drôle de société courageuse que
celle qui donne la parole à des anonymes
on se croirait sur les réseaux sociaux
monsieur bourdin
c'est ça le courage d'être anonyme
donc arrêtons les tergiversations
politiques alors à droite on tergiverse
pas trop apparemment et on s'indigne
mais on s'indigne qu'on s'en prenne aux
militaires écoutez en particulier sur ce
plan là l'euro député françois-xavier
bellamy alors je suis révoltée de voir
que certains choisissent de s'en prendre
aux messagers pour ne pas écouter le
message est qu'on est prêt à décrire ces
militaires qui servent la france comme
des factieux alors même qu'ils
expliquent dans leur texte que leur seul
et unique objectif c'est de défendre la
loi de la république et c'est de
défendre l'ordre public en france sur le
fond la tribune s'en prend aux
politiques qui ont traité de factieux
les généraux qui avait signé la
précédente tribune la première tribune
tribune dite des généraux et accuse des
politiques de ne pas combattre
l'islamisme que c'est une signataire ses
auteurs prétendent avoir combattu en
opérations extérieures notamment en
afghanistan et au sel et ce texte
persiste sur un point je cite la guerre
civile couvent sur tout le territoire
on peut également lire vous allez
pouvoir le dire avec moi ce n'est
peut-être pas des militaires de dire
cela à regret vous bien au contraire
parce que nous sommes apolitiques dans
nos appréciations de situation c'est un
constat professionnels que nous livrons
car cette déchéance nous l'avons vu dans
bien des pays en crise
elle précède l'effondrement elle annonce
le chaos et la violence
et contrairement à ce que vous affirmez
ici ou là ce chaos et cette violence ne
viendront pas d'un prononciez manteau
militaire entre guillemets mais d'une
insurrection civile sur le fond comme
sur la forme que pensez vous de ce texte
alexandre sur le sur la forme il est
peut-être plus réussi que le précédent
le me touré est un peu moins aux gros
sabots sur le fond j'étais d'accord avec
le précédent je suis d'accord avec celui
ci est effectivement en france oise
allier bel ami l'a bien résumé ya rien
de très nouveau
en réalité c'est pour ça que je m'étonne
de l'indignation qui avait suscité le
premier texte
gérald darmanin l'alleud s'indigne aussi
mais enfin il a parlé lui-même il ya peu
de guerre entre les policiers et les
trafiquants il a utilisé le mot guerre
il a expliqué que les soldats afin que
les policiers étaient des soldats donc
si je suis son raisonnement on est déjà
en quelque sorte en guerre civile
et ensuite c'est pas le seul le ministre
de l'intérieur avoir parlé comme ça
manuel valls a parlé de guerre contre
l'islamisme
gérard collomb a dit nos visions
côte-à-côte demain nous vivrons face à
face et françois hollande lui même
parlait de partition du pays
aof donc le sur le diagnostic je ne vois
pas pourquoi c'est choquant maintenant
il faut il faut agir
c'est peut-être qu'on attend des
politiques effet que vous avez en plus
de vouloir tuer celui qui sonne le
tocsin
d'accord on a compris votre point de vue
le vote christophe sur la j'allais dire
avant d'être sur le fond puisque c'est
une spécialité sur la forme qui ne se
distingue pas comme vous savez en fait
je serais un petit peu moins indulgent
que alexandre avec la forme je trouve
dans les deux tribunes même si en effet
la deuxième est meilleur je trouve que
des deux tribunes il ya quand même
il donne un petit peu quand même des dd
je veux dire des berges pour se faire
battre parce que vous avez là
un nom bien quelques ambiguïtés par
exemple ce sera pas un pronunciamiento
mais une insurrection civile
il n'est jamais dit par exemple donne
aucun des deux textes nous agirons ce à
la demande du gouvernement par exemple
donc je ne veux pas me faire le porte
parole de ceux qui attaquent les
militaires je trouve que quand même
rhétoriquement il pourrait être un peu
plus précis ce qui éviterait un peu plus
habile un peu plus habile
ce qui éviterait vous le comprenez bien
des procès d'intention
par définition seront là donc ils sont
justifiés les procès d'intention je ne
pense pas moi je suis sur le fond assez
d'accord est ce qu a dit alexandre mai
mais pour ne pas prêter le flanc à des
exploitations rhétorique trop facile qui
viendront de grands rhétoriciens car le
miz de l'intérieur remise de la justice
sont des grands et aux haïtiens et je
vous signale qu'ils ont quand même été
choisi pour cela
donc il faut quand même faire attention
à cela maintenant tout cela traduit la
surréaction à la tribune numéro un la
surréaction à la tribune numéro 2 ça
pose quand même des problèmes surtout un
moment où il faudrait plutôt sur réagir
à d'autres évènements et cela 7,7 hiatus
est en fait ce qui choque profondément
les français c'est à dire cette qualité
française indéniable
repéré par des cartes qui est le bon
sens c'est à dire qu' il vaut mieux
peut-être sans prendre d'abord aux
délinquants
ensuite éventuellement aux militaires
militaire que je je vois en place dans
un truc rhétorique qui est je dis bien
un truc rhétorique assez gros qui est la
fausse dichotomie c'est à dire que quand
il s'exprime en signant on les traite de
factieux quand il signe pas on les
traite de lâches
bon ça ne se fait pas beaucoup avancer
pardon pour la référence antique comme
on disait autrefois le schmilblick
il faudrait peut-être aller sur le fond
mais je dirais que le principal problème
et c'est pas souvent dit si j'étais le
gouvernement ce qui m'inquièterait le
plus c'est la fameuse phrase de juvénal
vous savez qui gardera les gardiens si
vous avez les policiers et les
militaires qui sont quand même les
derniers remparts où le premier et le
dernier rempart de l'ordre public qui
commence à être nerveux
être indigné et on est tout à fait sûr
j'ai fait de faire la moindre enquête
pour savoir que ça reflète l'opinion de
beaucoup d'entre eux combien je ne sais
pas mais beaucoup d'entre eux je serais
le gouvernement je m'inquiéterais un
petit peu quand même sur le fait du
désaffection de ceux qui sont chargés de
protéger les institutions
en tout cas vous avez une justement
pendant je coupe alexandre une analyse
justement sur ce sur ce thème là à
paraître dans le figaro dans les
prochaines heures
3 sur wii sur justement tous ces corps
de l'état régalien et qui tangue en ce
moment c'est ce que j'allais dire qu'il
faut ajouter à cela le la police qui est
mécontente qui a l'impression d'être
l'ag et la préfectorale donc on a les
ingrédients d'une crise de régime en
quelque sorte sur fond de voilà de crise
plus ancienne de l'autorité
effectivement
c'est le président le président de la
république ou enfin plutôt le
gouvernement show réagissons à peut-être
c'est peut-être est effectivement un
problème parce qu'il n'est jamais très
bon
en république d'avoir une désaffection
parce que je crois effectivement pas du
tout à un putsch à c'est effectivement
une blague etc et c'est ridicule mais
oui alors oui et d'ailleurs c'est un
petit désaccord avec christophe devaux
qui dit que c'est des excellents des
rhétoriciens je trouve la rhétorique un
peu usé la l'arrêt duc soir c'est pas la
réduction article héros mais enfin c'est
un procès quasiment en fascisme les
factieux etc
on voit bien que plus personne ne croit
en cela que d'ailleurs les sondages
avaient montré que l'aller et ça marche
les français d'accord avec avec cette
tribune à la marche est sa très
théorique
jean luc mélenchon a crié au complot et
à crier au putsch criaient ohhhhh
pronunciamento et florence parly qui
avait prévu dans un premier temps
d'après en tous les cas ce que ce que ce
que disent certaines informations
confidentielles de laisser passer le de
ne pas de pas ouvrir le dossier
finalement à taper du poing sur la table
devant des sanctions tord le bras de
l'état majeur oui ça a fonctionné mais
où prend voit bien qu'il ya un décalage
entre le pays je j'allais dire l'autre
le pays légal et le payer les réelles
mais entre les élites médiatiques et
politiques et les français puisque les
français donc pas du tout cru à cette
rhétorique et ont plutôt du coup a
approuvé approuvé les militaires je
pense que ça peut avoir une efficacité
je pense que c'est le but c'est
d'installer un duel entre la majorité et
le rassemblement national je pense que
l'idée c'est de faire disparaître la
droite du débat qui est le principal
adversaire des manuels mâcon et
d'installer ce duel
d'une certaine manière ça ils
participent et ça préfigure la probable
nullité du débat présidentiel
si on en reste là avec
finalement en marche qui se contentera
de dire votez pour nous puisqu'on n'est
pas des fascistes par rapport aux autres
je crois que ce serait terrible du point
de vue démocratique si le débat en
rester là
oui mais je vois aussi un autre danger
alors qu'il gardera des gardiens j'ai
véritablement la gourde de gouvernement
je dirais de gouvernement au quotidien
si par exemple il ya de nouveaux
troubles sociaux que fera vraiment la
police enfin il peut y avoir en tout cas
on va dire découragement au minimum 1
et puis je crois qu aussi autre chose
une petite musique que je sens monter
qui touche aussi la gestion du coc vide
qui touche les libertés publiques qui
touche énormément de sujets je dirais
une question intersectionnelle comme on
dit aujourd'hui qui est étrange
gouvernement genevois a dit musique
monté par exemple sur les réseaux
sociaux qui ont aussi des avantages
étrange gouvernement quand même qu'ils
tapent sur finalement des bons citoyens
où le citoyen ordinaire avec des lois
générales liberticide et puis qui ne se
concentre pas sur ce qui pose vraiment
problème c'est pas si le caricaturent d'
emmanuel chaunu notamment on voit les
maquereaux hurler contre des vieux
militaire en charentaises en disant il
va y avoir des sanctions
oui on bazarde actuellement j'ai vu
cette caricature et les caricatures
traduisent dans l'histoire de france
l'opinion publique et je pense je vous a
d'ailleurs qu'on était tellement attaché
au caricaturiste
je pense que cette petite musique là
notamment dans le cas d'un duel avec le
front national du rassemblement national
que d'ailleurs je remarque qu'on re
qualifie de plus en plus de front
national de façon polémique
je crois que cette petite musique là
pourrait être extrêmement
contre-productive
c'est à dire que je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec ce qu'alexandre de
l'équipe a dit mais le risque qu'on voit
pointer c'est que tout ce qui est dit
pour faire monter le front national ne
soit utilisée par le rassemblement
national décider moi-même le tombe dans
le dos au moment de la bataille suprême
et d'autre part qu' une majorité de
français puisse dire
au nom du bon sens où nous
justement de tout ce que je viens de
dire pourquoi votre âge pour la majorité
actuelle
donc on peut introduire un doute surtout
que le thème du front républicain qui
serait du coup uniquement la république
en marche serait quand même un peu usés
on le voit bien dans les sondages c'est
le piège on retournerait alors voilà
emmanuel macron c'est pour ça que je
trouve pas ça extraordinaire génial
peut-être peu probable je pense que sa
crainte aujourd'hui n'est pas là il est
lui convaincu qui battra le pen au
second tour et que son affaire c'est
donc le le premier toit mais
effectivement il commence à pointer je
sais pas si c'est un risque mais en tout
cas à risque que le piège se retourne
contre lui et que finalement le
rassemblement national puisqu'il sera la
seule alternance possible deviennent
l'alternance réel un autre une autre
question que vous soulevez finalement
cela en citant juvénal et qui gardera
les les gardiens est-ce qu'il ya pas là
deux erreurs enfin deux erreurs majeures
du quinquennat questions qui sont à la
fois le révéler par la sphère villiers
au début du quinquennat et un an plus
tard la sphère benalla d'affaires
villiers qui et je dirai plutôt
l'applaudissement qui est que convoi le
l'ovation qui a quand le général de
villiers démissionne spectacle on
n'avait jamais vu dans le dans la
communauté militaire et un an plus tard
la sphère benalla qui a été interprété
comme un lac comme une petite vengeance
delà de la police qui elle même avait
été méprisés par par emmanuel macron oui
quelle est la question est ce que c est
ce que là on n'en voit pas est ce qu'il
n'ya pas deux erreurs majeures du
du wydad emmanuel macron et qui continue
aujourd'hui qu'il continue aujourd'hui
de payer
oui surtout que je suis surtout si on si
le quinquennat se referme sur un nouvel
épisode méditerr après avoir commencé
par un épisode militaire mais ça des
historiens alors ça ça permettra de
faire des magnifiques dissertation en
vidéo on appelle ça un point est un
point à chacun sa référence mais je
pense que oui et les erreurs se
multiplient un petit peu actuellement je
trouve
envoyez le garde des sceaux au moment où
on est en pleine interrogation sur la
justice dans les roues de france
un garde des sceaux qui prétendent se
battre contre marine le pen alors que si
on fait la moindre petite réflexion
électorale de base on s'aperçoit que
c'est contre xavier bertrand enfin qu'il
est envoyé
donc je ne sais pas si beaucoup de gens
sont dupes
c'est quand même un petit peu un petit
peu énorme juste un mot sur le sur le
fait que le quinquennat commence avec
une brouille avec les militaires et
termine par une brouille avec les mille
pas encore terminée il est bientôt
terminée on rentre dans la phase de la
campagne électorale on est une réaction
aussi au fait que la tribune a été très
largement approuvé on voit qu'on est en
train de changer d'époque qui fut une
période allant de mai 68 où les
policiers les militaires étaient assez
mal vu dans la population on assiste à
un retour en force notamment de
l'institution militaire je parlais de
crise de régime tout à l'heure je pense
que ça peut traduire un futur
basculement des élites justement on a
des élites soixante huitards qui ont
pris le pouvoir en 81 d'ailleurs qui
sont plutôt des élites issues de la
technocratie on voit bien qu'on arrive
au bout de ses systèmes l'air et les
françaises cherchent autre chose et qui
se disent pourquoi pas une élite qui
viendrait du monde milite alors
l'éclairage de l'histoire justement sur
cette question on rappellera peut-être
comme en été
comment la vème république qui est
arrivé sur les fonts baptismaux mais
au-delà de ça l'armée ne ne veut pas et
ne peut pas être un recours et elle ne
veut pas l'être même si 48% des français
disent que pour être le plus le plus
inquiétant pour qu'il garderait les
gardiens qui gardera le gardien alors
peut-être que c'est justement le fait
que l'armée n'est pas dans la capacité
et de national maintien de l'ordre
et elle n'est pas aussi elle ne le veut
pas alors comment on sort comment on en
sort comment qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
comment on sort de cette situation
qu'est ce que doivent pas le pouvoir et
je trouve que enfin écoutez moi je suis
historien et pas politique
je regarde ça d'un historique mans
historiquement historiquement le général
de gaulle avait quelques problèmes avec
l'armée c'est bien mais les
circonstances étaient un petit peu
différente
et dans ce cas là il faut déjà s'assurer
de la majorité puisque général de gaulle
a su faire en contient le putsch par
exemple de s'assurer de la majorité des
militaires et pour cela il n'y a pas 36
façons de faire c'est à dire qu'il faut
aussi transmettre un message un peu plus
positif et pas seulement à les méchants
et c'est donc il faut trouver et pas se
rassurer en disant l'immense majorité
des militaires etc
il faut aussi répondre sur le fond je
crois qu'il était assez facile de dire
nous prenons en considération ce qui est
dit même si le désapprouvent on le fait
que les militaires
c'est quand même j'ai repensé la
déclaration de gérald darmanin mais je
voudrais qu'elle mollo la dernière soit
la lâcheté je trouve que le mot lâché
extrêmement mal choisie est vraiment
changer les choses parce qu'on ne traite
pas de l'âge des gens qui vont se faire
tuer pour la nation quand on est
ministre de l'intérieur et dont le
principal courage consiste à donner des
coups de menton je crois que là aussi je
serai très malvenues et et ça ne risque
pas de réponse il y est l'institution
avec avec le pouvoir
oui
et les charentaises s'était pas
extraordinaire non ils surent temps de
chanter je suis en plus se trouve
malvenu qu'on trouve ça que les
charentaises complètement dépréciatif la
question qu'on pose sur twitter c'est
signé anonymement cette tribune et il
entre guillemets un manque de courage
vous répondez non à 71% vous étaient
assez nombreux à répondre à cette
question plus que d'habitude quelques
unes de vos interventions général escape
dire que les militaires manque de
courage alors qu'ils vont au combat dans
des zones dangereuses c'est d'abord un
manque de respect ensuite un manque
d'intelligence
luis est sur twitter ça devrait
interpeller l'exécutif au lieu d'en
faire une polémique
beaucoup d'internautes qui disent qu'ils
ont signé le texte d'ailleurs sans être
militaire à venir alors en tous les cas
ceux qui le disent ne donnent leur
pseudo et donc nous savons qu'ils sont
le véritable manque de courage dit
napoléon et celui de nos gouvernements à
l'enap à lyon c'est un internaute et de
nos gouvernements successifs qui ont
laissé la situation s'empirer arcus guy
qui j'espère retrouver le son nous dit
d'écrire des faits précis concrets réels
et vérifiables s illégal signé une
tribune sans mettre son nom ce n'est pas
signé non valable estime en revanche
brady tôt et cet autre internaute qui se
fait appeler gardons espoir compte tenu
des sanctions promises par le
gouvernement aux signataires de la
première tribune
il était tout à fait prévisible que les
signataires de la seconde tribune fasse
le choix de l'anonymat et al'inverse
jean-claude estime qu'il faut avoir le
courage de ses actes dans n'importe quel
domaine je vous propose de revenir sur à
d'autres un autre événement de
l'actualité
cette fois-ci de ce week-end d'abord on
devrait en savoir un petit peu plus dans
les minutes qui viennent sur le profil
des suspects arrêtés cette nuit près
d'avignon avec dans le cadre de l'
enquête sur la mort du brigadier éric
masson en fin de semaine dernière
donc dans la cité des papes et derrière
l'émotion suscitée par la mort de ce
policier il y à la réalité et la réalité
elle a connu une nouvelle illustration
alors pas de policiers heureusement
tuées ce week end mais en revanche une
violence contre les policiers une
violence urbaine qui s'est illustré à
plusieurs endroits du territoire vous
avez regardé cette carte on va vous la
montrer qui a été préparé par le
lymphome la vidéographie du figaro kevin
d'hébuterne il y a d'abord vous l'avez
vu les images qui ont fait le tour des
jt des violences à fréjus mais il ya
aussi narbonne villefranche
rillieux-la-pape vaulx en velin vaulx en
velin brawn décines charpieu romans sur
isère pour toute la région rhône alpes
et en particulier autour de lyon et puis
en région parisienne autour de paris
versailles et l'encours trempe trappe
et puis dans l'essonne étampes corbeil
essonnes grigny également donc les ulis
voici donc le signe d'un échec c'est en
tout cas ce qu'estime l'ancien
commissaire européen est
vraisemblablement candidat à la
présidence de la république en tous les
cas il y pense plus qu'en se rasant
michel barnier insécurité c'est le
principal échec de ce quinquennat et que
c'est la principale demande à
principales exigences légitimes des
citoyens de notre pays qu'ils habitent
dans des villes dans des quartiers où il
faut combattre le trafic de drogue les
trafics en général via une exigence
légitime
d'autorité de rétablissement de
l'autorité républicaine ça passe par un
certain nombre de nouveaux comportements
de nouvelles décisions sans doute alors
on est d'accord pour les constats
christophe de vagues nouveaux
comportements nouvelle décision quelle
qu'elle devrait être les réponses du
gouvernement par rapport à ça le
gouvernement a trouvé une parade
rhétorique assez parce qu'elle est
habile je vous laisse la juger et mais
en dix ans en fait c'est parce que nous
donnons un coup de pied ce qu'ils
appellent le coup de pied dans la
fourmilière vous écouter tous les gens
de la république en marche utilise la
même expression sur tous les plateaux
il ya sans doute quelques éléments de
langage donc parce qu'il donne le
gouvernement donne dont donc à fond
contre les trafiquants de drogue cela
entraînerait leur réaction c'est ça que
c'est comme ça que je dis est créé le
narratif en usait de ses de ces
violences urbaines par le gouvernement
ce qui ce qui est quand même mettre un
petit peu aussi court
c'était un argument d'ailleurs de
nicolas sarkozy par rapport aux mêmes
jeunes médecins disaient que c'étaient
les trafiquants de drogue qui avait
absolument garder la carte que vous avez
montré va finir je crois qu'à la
prochaine édition de ce plateau ce sera
dans quelle ville il n'y a pas eu de
violences urbaines saillants plus vite
oui l'injuste qu'une petite correction
il me semble qu'en 2005 on avait même
dit plutôt au contraire que dans les
villes où il y avait beaucoup de trafic
dans les quartiers où il y avait
beaucoup de trafic il est moins il y
avait en réalité parce qu'ils
contrôlaient le quartier qui n'avait pas
forcément envie que ce soit le voilà le
le bordel par des mômes pardonnez moi
l'expression mais bonne correction en
tout cas la sergente en douceur selon
cette réponse rhétorique elle est très
claire mais elle pose un problème
vous y croyez pas ça pose un problème
parce que dans ce cas là on dit que ce
serait plutôt un nid de guêpes une
fourmilière en l'occurrence et donc
quand vous êtes pompiers que vous
affrontez un gameplay plutôt intérêt à
être protégée à être protégé est à
prévoir le coup et d'autre part ça pose
alors la question sur la politique de la
drogue en général la politique
de la france dans ce domaine qui reste
un sujet qui très débattue ou ne sont
pas dire forcément forcément d'accord
mais où en tout cas on ne voit pas le
début du commencement d'une réflexion
essayez c'est très martial encore drogue
quoi christophe vous ne croyez pas à la
halle explications du gouvernement c'est
parce que on fait la guerre contre le
trafic de drogue que cette violence on
les dérange donc ils se vengent par une
augmentation de viol et j'ai envie de
vous dire ce watts et on fait quoi à ce
moment là mais ce qui est étonnant par
exemple c'est qu'à fréjus il n'y a eu
aucune interpellation
donc visiblement à la faire il ya eu des
troubles majeurs ils quatre policiers
blessés
il n'y a eu aucune interpellation donc
la sphère est mal préparée où en est ce
que je veux dire c'est à dire que ce
sont des violences moi qui sont un
contrôle et tout ça tout ça traduit
quand même un manque de stratégie
opérationnelle élémentaire on peut pas
se contenter de dire allez hop on y va
et puis advienne que pourra
et donc je suis un petit peu un petit
peu sceptique et je crois qu'il y à il
ya aussi bien d'autres cas qui ce qui
explique ces violences urbaines
il n'y a pas que cette affaire tourne au
dessus là on va un peu vite en besogne
en imputant tôt à cette question il ya
aussi le sécessionnisme l'islamisme qui
reste toujours en arrière-plan
tout cela me paraît être au moins autant
facteurs de ce vieux de violence que la
courageuse héroïque lutte contre la
drogue aussi soudaine que martial et
pour laquelle j'aimerais encore une fois
qu'on est l'articulation d'une vraie
politique qui comprend par exemple comme
dirait le chef de l'état une réponse
pénale et que je suis d'accord sur le
fait que c'est une arnaque rhétorique la
question du trafic de drogue dont le
trafic de drogue et glisse
mêlez pas nouveau
il peut même jeu le rappela tout à
l'heure est paradoxalement un facteur
d'apaisement dans certains quartiers on
voit bien que pour les violences de
récentes il s'agissait pas uniquement du
trafic de drogue on n'a pas encore le
profil du tueur d'éric masson là il se
trouve que c'était sur un point de lille
mais pour la policière tuée à
rambouillet c'était une question
d'islamistes dans un autre fer et sans
qui je pense était marquant ce week-end
c'est le l'assassinât à mérignac sur un
parking de cette femme qu'on a brûlées
vivantes
on voit bien que là on n'est pas dans un
problème de trafic de drogue et je pense
que ce que les gens ressentent aussi au
quotidien dans ces quartiers là c'est
pas
voilà c'est le fait de ne pas pouvoir
sortir de chez eux à telle ou telle
heure de ne pas pouvoir emprunter telles
lignes de bus etc
donc on est dans une insécurité dans une
violence du quotidien qui n'est pas lié
au trafic de drogue je pense que je
parlais de chauffeurs de bus
cet été il ya également chauffeur de bus
qui avaient été tués ça a été un des
marques et en vidéo est là je sens son
nom m'échappe est donc voilà tous ces
exemples pour vous dire que je pense que
cette dépasse largement la question du
député afrique de danse devant la veuve
alors c'est d'ailleurs un appel au
président de la république oui et à
l'époque
emmanuel macron parlait de da civisme de
plus d'incivilités
donc on voit que le gouvernement on
n'arrive pas à faire le bon diagnostic
ou ne veut pas le faire le bon
diagnostic est celui d'une n'arrive pas
ou il faut pas le faire je pense que il
ya il n'arrive pas à résoudre c'est que
c'est problématique là où il veut pas
mettre le doigt sur un certain nombre de
sujets notamment sujet de l'immigration
je vais je vais y venir qui est lié au
sujet de la sécurité et donc il faut
tourner
effectivement le sujet je pense qu'on a
un problème de désintégration
nationale culturelle qui dépasse
d'ailleurs la simple question de
l'intégration dans une société de plus
en plus individualiste où il est très
difficile d'imposer des règles communes
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya dans ces
quartiers là un problème spécifique
d'intégration culturelle que n'a pas pu
résoudre toutes les politiques de la
ville par exemple et qui est lui une
immigration massive qui crée un
phénomène de ghettos et qui fait que ce
sont des états dans l'état en quelque
sorte ya pas que les policiers qu'ils
soient attaqués il ya aussi les pompiers
il ya aussi les médecins alors est ce
que justement et lorsque l'on est en
train de s que ce qu'on est en train de
voir ce que le spectacle auquel on y
assister c'est le signe plutôt que tout
simplement la police ne fait plus peur
et donc d'un recul de l'état même dans
les têtes
je voulais justement de revenir la dapo
lui strictement journalistique sur ce
qui s'est passé à fréjus où ça a été
partiellement force n'était pas du tout
lié au trafic de drogue
ça a été liée à un contrôle même pas un
contrôle d'identité d'ailleurs ça a été
simplement un rappel à l'ordre pour des
jeunes qui étaient dans la rue au delà
du couvre feu et qui mettait la pagaille
et la police est intervenue pour le duo
vous rentrez chez vous et ça a été ça
déclenche est véritablement des émeutes
considérable vous voyez ce qu'on disait
avec l exemple de vecchio je trouve que
là on a une facilité j'irais pas jusqu'a
une arnaque une facilité rhétorique qui
moi me laisse insatisfait quant au
diagnostic et encore une fois il n'y
aura pas de politique il n'y aura pas de
solution tant que le bon diagnostic est
pas posé ou poser un regret à reculons
regardez le premier le président ne
rapplique parle maintenant de réponse
pénale c'est la première fois
jusqu'à présent il y avait jamais proche
de problèmes de réponse pénale où il ya
un problème de réponse pénale ce qui est
dit par d'autres depuis très longtemps
donc on a l'impression que c'est petit à
petit que les problèmes sont enfin
reconnues on sort du déni mais on est
encore très loin alors qu'on est à moins
d'un an de l'homme puisque en fait comme
vont penser qu'on sort du déni
petit à petit
petit à petit sur la réponse pénale le
problème de la justice prend tout mettre
sur le la question de la police et des
forces de l'ordre
peut-être on a quand même nommé eric
dupond moretti qui était plutôt contre
les prisons et c'est quand même un
problème de cohérence et un moment et
d'incarnation le même dupond moretti qui
part en campagne régionale environnement
ce n'est peut-être pas le bon timing
donc il ya un problème de cohérence et
ensuite la question de l'immigration sur
laquelle j'ai glissé tout à l'heure qui
à mon avis ne peut pas être décoré de la
question de la sécurité
là pour le coup on continue de dettes
dans le déni je vous propose que dans
rodez bat mais une autre fois je crains
que hélas y ait d'autres occasions de le
faire
en tous les cas si j'en crois la réponse
que vous faites et que vous avez apporté
à la question que vous a posé sur
twitter les réponses du gouvernement
face aux violences urbaines sont elles
suffisantes et vous répondez non à 91%
là aussi vous avez été très nombreux à
répondre godonou dit elles sont surtout
inadaptée et ce depuis fort longtemps on
n'éteint pas un incendie en cherchant à
attraper les flammes
axel encore une fois une tolérance zéro
peut régler le problème
c'est une question d'ailleurs c'est un
site et une formule qu'on entend plus
est ce que ce serait pas une des pistes
font toujours pouvoir la mettre en
oeuvre
et encore une fois on peut attraper les
gens s'ils sont relâchés dans la nature
ou même s'il n'ya pas de places de
prison pour appliquer les peines qui
sont parfois données par les juges
on ne sort si on ne sortira pas c'est
pour ça qu'il faut qu'il y ait de la
cohérence et il faut un changement de
politique globale et pas seulement des
mesures est passée par là précision pour
les millénium la tolérance zéro c'est
une politique qui est émise en d'abord
par rudolph giuliani à new york et
ensuite par tony blair en grande
bretagne en particulier à londres qui
consistait à sanctionner toutes les
incivilités c'est à dire la fois les
crimes bien entendu mais également les
délits et encore plus les petits délits
qu'ils étaient
qui étaient commis et ça a fait reculer
la sécurité en particulier à new york
si les réponses suffisait elle cesserait
c'est du bon sens nous dit françois et
avec respect si un délinquant tir de
vraies balles de policiers doivent faire
pareil
c'est là toute la question autour de la
légitime défense et xavier nous il faut
qu'on vient de sondage pour comprendre
que les français ne se sentent pas en
sécurité et bien en tous les cas vous
avez répondu à la question qu'on vous a
posé sur twitter qui n'est pas un
sondage
on vous en remercie on continuera le
débat est bien entendu on recommande les
notes de la fondapol et tout le travail
de fondapol dont christophe préside le
conseil scientifique et leur composition
le nouveau monde populiste c'est le
dernier livre absolument à lire
d'alexandre ii vecchio et bien sûr vous
pouvez tout de suite sur figaro vox voir
les dernières productions merci beaucoup
de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
demain même heure même endroit
à très vite sur figaro live